[Music]
one of the key themes that philip k dick
is
i won't even say playing around with
because he makes it so centrally
important for the humans
into android's dream of electric sheep
is the gradual breaking down of things
and we can sum it up in a couple
different terms
kipple a term that he's going to
introduce in the mouth of isidore the
character here
form destroying or entropy
and then something that he calls the
tomb world
and i do want to point out at the start
before we go into this too far
that this notion of form destroying this
shows up as well in
a maze of death there's something very
much like the tomb world in a martian
time slip so these are not themes that
are
totally confined or language totally
confined to this story
alone
so in post-emigration
earth that is after this war has taken
place and there's radioactive dust
everywhere and colonization is happening
many of the earth's animals have
died off people are leaving
the earth is becoming this quite empty
place and the emptiness
is something you could say
oppressive and also a location
where kipple entropy breakdown can
happen and even accelerate and we find
this already coming up with
decker rick decker's wife erin decker
who is talking about the building and
this is in chapter one
i was sitting here one afternoon she
said naturally i turned on buster
friendly and his friendly friends and he
was talking about a big news item and
that awful commercial came on so for a
minute i shut off the sound
and i heard the building this building i
heard the she gestured
empty apartments rick said sometimes he
heard them at night when he was supposed
to be asleep and yet for this day and
age a one-half occupied conapt building
rate high in the scheme of population
density out in what had been before the
war the suburbs one could find buildings
entirely empty or so he had heard and
she says at that moment when i had the
tv sound off i had dialed the 382 mood
so i heard the emptiness intellectually
but i didn't feel it and then she said i
realized how unhealthy it was
sensing the absence of life not just in
this building but everywhere reacting
not reacting do you see i guess you
don't
that used to be considered a sign of
mental illness they called it absence of
appropriate affect and she experiments
with her mood organ until she can find
one for despair
so
she's she's sensing she's hearing
something that's not there namely
life
human life
animal life
is the door uh in his empty apartment
building is going through something
quite similar
and uh we see this happening in chapter
two this is
here we go silence it flashed from the
woodwork and the walls it smote him with
an awful total power as if generated by
a vast mill it rose from the floor up
out of the tattered gray wall-to-wall
carpeting it unleashed itself from the
broken and empty semi-broken appliances
in the kitchen the dead machines that
hadn't worked in all the time isidore
had lived there from the empty pole lamp
in the living room it oozed out meshing
with the empty and wordless descent of
itself from the fly specked ceiling it
managed to emerge from every object
within his range of vision as if it the
silence meant to
supplant all things tangible it assailed
not only his ears but his eyes
and he goes on he says he experienced
the silence as visible and in its own
way
alive he had often felt its austere
approach before when it came it burst
without subtlety evidently unable to
wait the silence of the world could not
reign back its greed silence the void is
another word he'll use later on
is waiting there to take us all
back
into its embrace
it goes on he wondered then if the
others who had remained on earth
experience the void in this way or was
it peculiar to his own peculi was it
peculiar to his own peculiar biological
identity
a freak generated by his inept sensory
apparatus
interesting question isadore thought but
whom could he compare notes with
he lived alone in this deteriorating
blind building
of a thousand uninhabited apartments
which like its counterparts fell day by
day into greater entropic
ruin eventually everything within the
building would merge would be faceless
and identical mere pudding like kipple
piled to the ceiling of each apartment
and after that the uncared for building
itself would settle into shapelessness
buried under the ubiquity of the dust by
then naturally he himself would be dead
another interesting event to anticipate
as he stood here in his stricken living
room alone with a lungless
all-penetrating
masterful
world silence so we've got an
amazing phenomenological description
here of what this silence and what this
process of breakdown looks like you
notice he's using the word kipple there
which he'll later define in talking with
another entity as we'll get to in just a
moment
and we've got the concept of form
destroying going on as well everything
returning to a formless
state so what is
kipple well
we find out with a little bit of info
dumping a little bit of expository
stuff as isidor is explaining this to
pris
the android who has made it there and
she is in one of the apartments and he's
you know going into her apartment he
says
we really need to change this the car
the chairs the carpet the table all had
rotted away they sagged in mutual ruin
victims of the despotic force of time
and of abandonment so he said listen if
we go over the building
we can probably find you some things
that aren't so tattered a lamp from one
apartment a table from another
and he talks about um you know going in
with her to help out
how you know kind of scary and
oppressive it is going into apartments
by yourself
and then he says
this building
except for my apartment
is completely capabilized and she says
capitalized what is that and he says
kipple
is useless objects like junk mail or
match folders you use after the last
match or gum wrappers or yesterday's
homeopape when nobody's around kipple
reproduces itself for instance if you go
to bed leaving any kipple around your
apartment when you wake up the next
morning there's twice as much of it it
always gets more and more
the girl regarded him uncertainly not
knowing whether to believe him not sure
if he meant it seriously there's the
first law of kipple he said kipple
drives out
non-kipple
um
like gresham's law about bad money and
in these apartments there's been no one
there to fight the kipple
and then he says this place the
apartment you've picked is to kippalize
to live in we can roll the kipple factor
back we can do like i said raid the
other apartments but
but what
we can't win
why not the girl stepped into the hall
no one can win against kipple he said
except temporarily and maybe in one spot
like in my apartment i sort of created a
stasis between the pressure of kipple
and non-kipple for the time being but
eventually i'll die or go away and then
the kipple will again
take over it's a universal principle
operating through the universe
the entire universe is moving towards a
final state of total absolute
capitalization
except of course for the upward climb of
wilbur
mercer so
if we hear it in these frame you know
the universal principle
kipple is entropy but kipple is also the
manifestation
of it in terms of you know things like
rotting mildew breakdown
but also what form these things
originally had as human
artifacts as appliances as furnishings
so there's a very interesting you know
way in which this is taking place
some other considerations about entropy
deckard himself as he is hunting uh his
quarry
the uh
opera singer
and um
he says to himself is he's listening to
a rehearsal of the magic flute
thinking of this
the magic bells that would make your
enemy disappear
and how mozart was buried in an unmarked
pauper's grave he wondered if mozart had
any intuition that the future did not
exist that he'd also used up his little
time maybe i have two rick thought as he
watched the rehearsal move along
this rehearsal will end
the performance will end
the singers will die
eventually the last score the music will
be destroyed in one way or the other
finally the name mozart will vanish
the dust will have won if not on this
planet then another
we can evade it for a while so we're
talking again about the process of
breakdown the process of
meaning turning into meaninglessness the
process of form turning into
formlessness the process of non-kipple
turning into kipple
and then he says
as the andes can evade me and exist to
finance stretch longer but i get them or
some other bounty hunter gets them and
then he has a realization
in a way
i'm part of the form destroying process
of entropy the rosen cr the erosion
association creates
and i unmake or so it must seem
to them
it's a very interesting realization that
he is part of the process of destruction
right he is a form
destroyer right but he's got form
himself and he's doing it in order to
preserve
human life at least
then we have the tomb world
this comes up a little bit earlier in
the work
and this is where isidore is in fact
um
you know engaged in the and the
empathy box and engaging and merging
with wilbur mercer and all the other
people
and there's a really interesting uh
discussion of this in chapter two
it says
once it had been different back before
the curse had come an earlier happy part
of life
they his foster parents frank and cora
mercer had found him floating on an
inflated rubber air rescue raft off the
coast of new england he goes on and he
talks about bringing back dead animals
as they had had been
and then local law prohibited this time
reversal faculty
he continued to do it secretly but an
old woman he'd never seen her heard of
it told without his parents consent they
the killers had bombarded the unique
nodule which had formed in his brain
attacked it with radioactive cobalt this
plunged him into a different world a
world whose existence he had never
suspected this is the tomb world
it had been a pit of corpses and dead
bones and he'd struggled for years to
get up from it
the donkey and especially the toad the
creature's most important him had
vanished had become extinct only
rotting fragments
an eyeless head here
part of a hand there remained
at least at last a bird which had come
there to die told him where he was he
had sunk down into the tomb world so
this is something that
isidore himself thinks of himself
perhaps you know falling
into as we're gonna we're gonna talk
about
but mercer has
lived through this he was trapped in the
tomb world and then
he could not get out until the bones
strewn about him grew back into living
creatures
or he he had become joined to the
metabolism of other lives and until they
rose he could not either how long that
part of the cycle would last that he did
not now know nothing had happened
generally so it had been measureless but
at last
the bones had regained flesh the empty
eye pits had filled up and new eyes had
seen
meanwhile the restored beaks and mouths
had cackled barked and caterwauled
possibly he'd done it perhaps the extra
sensory note of his brain had grown back
or perhaps he hadn't accomplished it
very likely it could have been a natural
process anyhow
he was no longer sinking he'd begun to
ascend
with the others
long ago he lost sight of them he found
himself evidently climbing alone but
they were there they accompanied him he
felt them strangely
inside him so this is the the memories
of mercer
mercer who is an unusual being who can
resist this this entropizing
process
and everybody who fuses with them
including john isadore
a special
who
is confined to this
you know apartment way out in the
middle of nowhere
and who is um
in a certain sense
breaking down himself
all of this is part of the
process that's going on
isidore suggests that as he deteriorates
further and further
in his life perhaps he is actually
falling into the tomb world himself
maybe this is what happens to all of the
so-called
specials
that like uh isidore are not allowed to
emigrate and are confined either to very
menial jobs or to institutions
there's also a breakdown that happens in
isidore's apartment after the androids
kill off the
well they don't kill the spider they cut
off four of its legs
and then try to get it to
work and
we see the apartment
breaking down into kipple right we hear
this
the spider is gone mercer's gone he saw
the dust and the ruin of the apartment
as it lays spreading out everywhere he
heard the kipple coming
the final disorder of all forms the
absence which would win out
it grew around him as he stood holding
the empty ceramic cup the cupboards of
the kitchen creaked and split and he
felt the floor beneath his feet give
reaching out he touched the wall his
hand broke the surface gray particles
trickled and hurried down fragments of
plaster resembling the radioactive dust
outside he seated himself at the table
in like rotten hollow tubes the leg of
the chair bent standing quickly set down
the cup and tried to reform the chair
tried to press it back into its right
shape
the chair came apart
in his hands
he saw on the table the ceramic cup
crack
webs of fine lines grew like shadows of
a vine then a chip dropped from the edge
of the cup exposing the rough
unglazed exterior the androids say
what's he doing he's breaking everything
is the door stop and he says i'm not
doing it
he walked unsteadily into the living
room to be by himself
and he says everything is old it has
long been ago begun to decay and it
won't stop the corpse of the spider has
taken over
he starts descending into the tomb world
and he says it's happening to me again
i'll be down here a long time as before
it's always long because nothing here
ever changes a point comes when it does
not even decay
but in this case
mercer
saves him
mercer
gives him a spider back maybe the spider
or a different spider
and mercer uh
helps him out of
the tomb world as he talks to him and
says yes
all this stuff is true the video footage
is is really a fraud you know i was an
actor but
that doesn't mean that what's happening
metaphysically isn't
really going on and so
we do have a way of overcoming this
entropy we might also have other ways
too
it's hinted
that perhaps
love love between human beings
based on empathy
is a way of suspending the
process of entropy and form destroying
keeping us out of the tomb world
at least for
a while now this is something that the
androids don't really seem to be
bothered by or even
notice or
cognize all that much this is a
distinctively
human
problem within this world of do androids
dream of electric sheep
you